[Music]
does anybody know any uh polyamorous
people wait what's the difference yeah
what's the difference between
polyamorous and polygamous
polygamy it's more and molly
i
does anyone know and polyester what's
what's this whole thing i'm here i think
that's from polynesia yeah and polly
pocket you remember that
polly pocket pocket i do remember
though do we know the distinction
somebody say something
did you say playstation i should just
play with a polly pocket
polygamist is more about marriage like
having multiple people oh okay and
spouses and then polyamorous
it's just love and affection love for
everybody but how much everyone's
getting it i don't know about everything
i think it's love for more than one how
much love though are we talking here
like unlimited amounts over polyamory
yeah
are you familiar with polyamory at all
no i don't know auntie go ahead school
yeah he's a pretty polyamorous man
as our local sex have her
in the room i just found out what
polyamorous meant little side combo
anthony has a lot a lot of stuff so like
we any time we have questions oh his
reputation precedes him like we all know
in the dance community i heard it's
notorious yeah yeah yeah i never know
where to go with that bit you told me
something last night that i'm going to
work in the conversation i'm not but i
haven't if you i swear to god there are
things that i tell you steve i'm off
camera and i'm going to expose it yeah
but you can't tell steve things when
he's drunk because he's not going to
remember he's going to tell you
everything exactly right the [ __ ] dude
speaking of polyamorous oh yeah i
thought you're gonna tell us a little
bit about something point it to me man
but you could be in a relationship and
be polyamorous like that is part of it
see i love both my fiance and i love you
yeah have not told you i love you but
you never come over and kick it have i
told you i love you you know what i mean
yeah so we're polyamorous no i think
it's more than that
okay when i looked in your eyes we're
butt naked and then i said i love you
but you're not polyamorous until we all
[ __ ] yeah if we we get all [ __ ] is the
thing but that's part of it
the sex is a big part of it
you know so i think we're totally
bullied
i feel like all the boxes are getting
checked right now what else do we need
huh feeling neglected but stephen fry's
gay he isn't like anal sex what like
receiving
so he's not he's not gay then yeah he's
like no he he's gay no he's god yeah i
don't believe he's gay he won't accept
that he's not gay yeah yeah yeah you
gotta commit you gotta like it yeah
so how does he have sex blow jobs that's
it that's not sex according to bill
clinton that's what yeah
and he didn't inhale so so he's a virgin
pretty much
that's interesting stephen fry um
now really really doesn't know good
let's keep it that way so there's this
polyamorous relationship where uh you
have a married uh couple
in a polyamorous relationship with
another married couple and they
basically have a household and that
that's called a polygon
yes
right and they live in one big house and
they have kids and nobody in the family
knows whose kids is what yeah who's like
because they have interviews they have
sex all the time yeah do moms shoot ads
they have they like switch partners
every now and then i like the mormon
kind of polyamorous better interesting
low key though if you are really uh if
you're a polyamorous enthusiast that's
probably the best setup no mormon one is
why
why is this a very large argument set up
why why joe why don't you tell me dude
because well in your how will you swing
both ways so i think you like it right
but for me
i don't so i wouldn't want other guys in
my territory
and i want to know if they're my
children dude i'm not bisexual man
you're i know you're more gay than
bisexual but you are bisexual you can
have a higher gay than bisexual right i
was like how do you kind of like justify
it's my values
it's a metric-centric system well it's
on the spectrum they say they say gay is
a spectrum right and his irvine
sexuality's on a spectrum yeah but his
sexuality is like all over the place if
your wife does analysts she's gay
yeah i think so
if you're a wife
that's why i don't we're like we're not
doing that okay we're not crossing that
line sweetheart okay so i tell her i
think we're figuring this out
dude no [ __ ] though i was i remember i
was talking to this girl on the phone
because it made me [ __ ] crack up i
remember this [ __ ] and then
we're like we haven't had sex yet we're
just dating right we're just kind of
flirting and she goes yeah my
ex-boyfriend i think he was gay and i'm
like why
he just always like wanted to do anal
sex with me and i'm like
how does that make you gay you're a
woman nah that's gay right but she swore
that he was gay
maybe you wanted to just brought that
back at me he wanted her to put stuff in
his butt no that's pegging yesterday she
liked it she she didn't like it but she
was getting it in the butt and then she
was accusing him of being gay that's a
maker's mark for that yeah we gotta make
like 50 things at home depot they can do
that
i have i have seen that though i did
have a friend that was the same way
where he would hook up with girls and
always that was his mission like he only
wanted to do it in the butt and then did
the girls all accuse him of being gay no
because they never they they don't know
the frequency in which he's doing that
only we do well
that's i would just just that just
confused me you know what i mean i was
just so confused do you think it's gay
no it's a walker you think it's yeah i
can definitely think no yeah i don't
like i don't know
i'm not seeing nick like this in a
minute hey shut up dude i'm not laughing
bro this is a serious conversation he's
crying respect the conversation
it's just this whole laughing he just
it's joe asking the question like that's
not gay this full starts snickering and
i just started laughing i just sometimes
can't believe how stupid we all are
[Laughter]
it's like it's only been six minutes and
it's just like what are we talking about
i think like one of the
the biggest jokes the biggest funniest
thing is is like so quickly accusing
things of being gay or not gay
that's my favorite thing that's the best
thing because we were all raised around
that yeah so
getting to play that part here is really
fun yeah anybody who's really young but
basically that's a satirical take on
what things used to be like but now it's
like you're so self-aware that that's
wrong how stupid that is to be like
that's gay that's not gay that's good i
don't know what satire is but it sounds
good to me
when you explain satire that's gay yeah
that's that's not something to be doing
i think it's so funny that like you
could you can like file through all
these different actions that could be
done to your butt or someone else's and
that's how hard you have to go and dig
to find out am i gay
it's like you either are you're not but
no no no and that's what blows my mind i
mean in my statement right where it was
a woman that was saying this and this is
if everyone in that era women and men
would sit there and be like yo that's
kind of gay yeah he likes anal sex yeah
that's dude like but in the context of
your friend in that situation huh in
that context of your friend in that
situation her boyfriend was gay
that's accurate that tacky according to
according to our findings thus far that
is accurate yeah like that full of yeah
when i wanted to go see musicals right
but i wanted to go with the woman as my
date am i gay
oh for wanting to go see did you have
little sex at the musical
was it red i've been called gay for that
i've been called gabe for wanting to do
to go see a musical with a woman
oh
other gay guys
they're the authority so dude i got
called gay for getting an a in my typing
class
let's go around the room this is good
that's so true
i got gay i got called gay for making a
clay pot
in school like fourth grade yeah i made
a clay pot that's pretty good yeah they
thought they were like that's gay i was
like i just i had to make it for art
classes
dude that happens all the time though i
got called gabriel making like the best
[ __ ] snowflake
maybe that's gay though
that's like hey it's actually kind of
good i know right it's like
that's actually
no one ever like gave you a hard time
for being gay when you were going
growing up that doesn't happen to girls
no they they immediately assume that i
am
that was so crazy have you ever like uh
it doesn't work the opposite way where
like let's say you're with you're with a
dude who expects you to be more feminine
and because you make a choice that's not
the typical girl choice does he like
raise an eyebrow kind of like raises it
at himself like um
wait i'm in a dude
his eyebrows raised at you and then he
looked at himself in the mirror
he's like i gotta go to the bathroom
really quick washes his face looks in
the mirror the reflection of the mirror
is like you're gay
no the reflection is like yo you're gay
oh my god uh mark spector you're gay
that's never happened in any situation
and that always happens it always
happens yeah
yeah and then they'll make some kind of
remark they'll be like oh you're not
into that why not you don't like that
you don't like me
you don't like fake i really don't like
pink though you don't like pink what
kind of woman are you i know
i'm not you never go shopping that's
weird it's weird
she sounds gay or
weird
oh no
not a fan my wife likes pink but she's
also a professional poker player which i
think is very butch
that's great i was like i'm instantly
intrigued because i'm like i love poker
oh you do yeah oh dude
yeah oh [ __ ]
his wife recently did the world series
of poker and one and got and was top
four yeah
she's a female poker player were there
other females in the top four not on the
final table she's not a fun people yeah
she beat them all
yeah she suppressed all three she was
only allowed there for being female
it wasn't an all girls game it's a
handicap to be a little girl's
handicapped like we need one female so
uh whatever you are taking there isn't
all girls my world series of poker oh
there's why why do you need to like yeah
what is the point of that they separate
the genders in poker no no it's just an
optional one they did it because i think
the chicks are tired of dude [ __ ] so
like we just wanna we just wanna all
check one so we can just not have to
deal with all the [ __ ] it's all
queens
it's like yeah
it's like the all-female gyms how it's
like yo please just stop hitting on us
we just want to [ __ ] leave like the
lady trains in japan they're sick that
makes you use that to
if anything like women have more
leverage than that that's true there's a
lot of guys that just want to beat girls
up or like look at their titties and
then they lose is that how the wnba was
started i
i'm not i'm not familiar with i think
after johanna man they started the wnba
the [ __ ] after jawana man
so lost in this video where'd she win
she won 116 000. okay yeah that's pretty
great you both won
he won 50 of that all i know is my house
got about to get filled with even more
plants
and steve's about to finally come out
the closet right and i'm good
i'm filling up those houses with plants
i'm about to get some plants and i'm
good
dude you're an athlete's husband i have
to tell my wife
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you